[Music]
yeah yeah somebody well going back to
the well and going back again and and
then putting a drill in that just sucks
that well let me start over
Steve so good to have you here you know
I it's such a thrill for me to have you
on the show I've always been such a big
fan of yours well I would like to repay
the way I'd like to repay the compliment
I really would however and I'm that's it
that's really if we can play view love
that you know however it's just you know
over you know wanting wanting is not
doing and I've the headline is the top
ten things Conan O'Brien will say to
ruin this top 10 list Steve alright
that's great I just don't want and then
I will go into it yeah
number 10 you want to try one I really
do love your show and I love the way you
know I love on shows like yours when
you're able to establish running bits
that you can go back to your standard
standard things you can go back to and
go back to that comedy well the audience
loves it and you're able to go back to
the well and go back to the well and
drill and drill and just suck that well
just just get that comedy to come up
until it's just arid really nothing left
you're able to still go down you can
feel the sucking sound yeah yeah I've
always wanted to participate one of your
classic comedy bit so so I've prepared
one of my own beloved top ten
the top ten list that was my fault the
top ten things Conan O'Brien will say to
ruin this top ten list
Steve I I don't want to ruin this for
you but that's Letterman's bid number
ten that's Letterman's bid
I'm not kidding Steve Letterman's been
doing top ten lists for like thirty year
for over 30 years
number nine I'm not kidding Steve
Letterman has been doing top ten list
over thirty years
no really you got to stop this number
eight no really you've got to stop this
who's gonna have a copyright issue with
these graphics number seven I think
we're going to have a copyright issue
with these graphics Steve number six
Steve please please
then Conan throws up his hands and
regular resignation finally saw his
kooky stuff number three who the hell is
that Steve I appreciate your commitment
to this bit I really do I'm asking you
as a friend to please stop doing this
top 10 list we've done a lot of great
comedy butts on this show this is
definitely not one of them it's almost
disrespectful to Letterman's incredible
legacy to do his top 10 list on our show
even as a joke so I ask you one last
time will you please stop a really long
thing that Conan says it goes on and on
and on ba bla bla bla bla
something-something please stop I kind
of tuned out while number one think
owner will say to ruin this top 10 list
is okay let's take that I'm sorry a rip
rip rip we're out of time we're out of
time
[Music]
so great
[Music]